- [Voiceover] The table above,
I put it to the left here
so that it all fits on this screen.
The table above shows the results
of a 2007 observational study
that looked at the birthdays
of the players on the amateur
Canadian youth hockey championship team.
Based on the results of this study,
which of the following conclusions
are valid?
So, we look at the different players.
So this is player number nine,
born on January 4, 1988.
Player number 16,
born on January 10, 1987.
So, we have the birthdays
of all of the different
players on the team
and we need to make,
let's see, what are these
conclusions talking about?
There is an association between players
being on the 2007 amateur
Canadian youth hockey championship team
and being born between January 1
and June 30 in their year,
in their year of birth.
Alright, so it looks like
we're going to try to find
some relationships,
some association
between when you're born
and your odds of being on this team.
So let's see, let's see.
There's no association
between players being on,
between players being on the 2007 amateur
Canadian youth hockey championship team
and being born between January 1
and June 30 in their year of birth.
Canadian hockey players
born in 1987 are more likely
to become professional hockey players
than Canadian hockey players born in 1989.
More players on the 2007 amateur
Canadian youth hockey championship team
were born in 1987 than any other year.
So, let's, let's actually,
since we're talking about
associations between
when your birthday was,
whether it's some kind of the first half
of the year
or what year it is.
Let's actually do a little bit of a,
and look, everything is,
they're not saying
associations between January
and February.
They're just really talking about
the first half of the year
or comparing from one year to another.
So actually, let's,
let me make a plot here.
So, I'll do a little bit of a,
I'll, let me do a little
histogram right over here.
So, let's see,
we have people born
as early as 1987,
going all the way to 1989.
So let's just talk about
the two halves of the year.
So let's say that this is first half.
So this is, you know,
kind of, let's say one,
1/87 to 6/87.
So this is the people
born in the first half
of 1987.
This would be 7/87 to 12/87
and that's the people born
in the second half of 1987.
Then you have,
you have 1/88 to 6/88,
first half of 88
and then you have the second half of 88.
So 7/88 to 12/88
and then, I'm going off the screen here,
let's just go
because we do go all they way to 89.
So then you have,
then you have,
you have 1/89.
So January of 1989 thru June of 89.
So the first half of 89
and then the second half,
7/89 to 12,
whoops,
to 12,
to 12/89.
So, let's see how many people
there are in each of these.
So, in this first group
and I'm going to color code it,
this first group right over here,
first half of 1987.
First half of 1987,
player number 16 is January 87.
This is January 87.
This is March 87,
so that counts.
This is before June.
This is, let's see,
we have one, two, three, four players.
So I can maybe say one,
two, three, four players.
And now let's say second half of 87.
So, let's see,
out of the 87 folks,
there's two folks in the second half.
So one and two.
Now let's,
now let's look at 88.
So, first half of 88.
There, there, there, there.
Yep, those are,
so there's one, two,
three, four people born
in the first half of 1988.
Now let's see,
second half of 1988,
it doesn't look like we have anybody.
And then we just have one more person
whose born in the first half of,
born in the first half of 89.
So, March 89.
So they're born in the first half of 89.
So just looking like,
looking at this,
in 1987 you have disproportionately
more people born in the
first half of the year
than the second half of the year,
which wouldn't be true
of the general population.
The general population,
I don't know the data for sure,
but I would expect that it's
more evenly distributed.
We see in 88,
everyone is born in 1988
was only born in the first half.
And then in 89 we only
have one data point,
but they were born in the
first half of the year.
So, let's look at this.
Let's look at these choices.
There is an association
between players being
on the 2007 amateur
Canadian youth hockey championship team
and being born between January 1
and June 30 in their year of birth.
Yeah, it looks like it.
It looks like, you know,
they have disproportionately many people
born in the first half of the year.
So I like this statement.
We see that here.
87, disproportion in the first half.
88, everyone's in the first half.
89, everyone's in the first half.
There's no association between players
being on the 2007 amateur
Canadian youth hockey championship team
and being born, essentially,
in the first half of the year.
Well, we just,
you can't pick both of these.
Only one of these two
are going to be true.
Canadian hockey players born in 1987
are more likely to become
professional hockey players
than Canadian hockey players born in 1989.
Well, were not talking about
professional hockey players.
We're talking about the youth
hockey championship team.
So, I really wouldn't be in the mood
to make any statement
about the probability of people
becoming professional hockey players.
You might say, okay,
if you're on the youth team,
you're more likely to become professional,
but once again, the only reason why
you had more people in 87 than 89
is that we're looking
at the championship team
for a particular year
and in a particular year,
of course you're going to have more folks
from, in the older years
than in the,
than the folks who are younger,
but than the championship
team in two years
is going to have a bunch of people from 89
as these people mature.
And we definitely can't
say anything about,
now that's just the
youth championship team,
we're not saying anything about
professional hockey players.
More players on the 2007 amateur Canadian
and actually, you know,
we can, let's see,
more players on the 2007 amateur
Canadian youth hockey championship team
were born in 1987
than any other year.
Well, yeah, this data is literally
for the 2007 amateur
Canadian youth hockey championship team
and we do, indeed,
see that more folks were born in 1987,
six folks were born in 1987,
than the four in 1988
and the one in 1989.
And so I think that is a fair,
this right over here is a fair statement.
And this is just for the 2007 team
and it'll change for the 2008 team
and the,
and the 2009 team.
And so, I like one and four
and they have a choice
that is one and four.